If you've gone to a tech conference,
literally any tech conference
in the last five years,
you would walk away with the impression
that the connected, easy-to-navigate,
clean and green smart city
is just around the corner.
The reality and the hype is
that many companies are working
on products and solutions to get there.
Take transportation, for example.
Allegedly, in the city of the future
you will be able to seamlessly plan
your journey from public transportation
to shared autonomous taxis
and even electric scooters.
If you own a car, it will be electric,
and there will be charging stations
strategically placed throughout the city.
So all you do is type
your location into your GPS,
and it will automatically
take you to your location
in the minimum amount of time
and any payment you need for charging
will be done automatically
in the background.
Now you might say, wait a minute,
there are companies
that are doing this today.
I can do this today.
But it’s individual companies,
and it's certainly not ubiquitous
across the city.
But it doesn't just stop
with transportation.
Let's take health.
In the future, there will be air-quality
monitors at every street corner,
and they will be connected
with your asthma inhaler
so that you know when it's safe to go out.
Or there will be infrared cameras
that are measuring the temperature
of citizens anonymously
and that will be connected
with your thermometer
so that we can detect future outbreaks.
And of course, you will also have
your wearable device
that connected to your bathroom scale
and your smart refrigerator
so that nutritionists, doctors
and other companies
can come up with new ways
to keep you, you know,
slim and and trim as I am.
Then of course, there's shopping.
I mean, when you shop today, you know,
you purchase from different retailers
and you receive multiple shipments
during the course of the day.
Now, if you had an app
where you could set your preferences
and those shipments can be consolidated
and maybe you receive
fewer shipments during the week,
a little bit less convenient,
but you get to reduce
your carbon footprint.
So these are all great ideas
and solutions and products
that companies are working on,
but they all share
an underlying requirement
that could make that smart city
more of a distant dream
than a reality just around the corner.
And that is the need for greater sharing
of data across companies,
individuals and cities.
And if there's one thing
that we've learned
is that companies
don't like to share data,
they don't even like to share
our own data with us.
So let alone data
with competitors or partners.
And therein lies the dilemma,
because if we want to have a chance
at really combating climate change,
we need to have our cities become
as smart and as connected
as quickly as possible,
and as many cities as possible.
So we need to overcome
this fear of data sharing
and move towards the smart-city future.
But why is it that companies
fear sharing data?
Well, it’s what I call “FOMA”.
Not FOMO,
the fear of missing out
on a great party or either opportunity,
but FOMA, the fear of missing out
on competitive advantage.
Data is a source of competitive advantage.
So why would companies want to give it up?
In our research, over the last two years,
we've been looking
at many different solutions
that would improve the citizen experience
and as well sustainability
solutions for cities.
And what we found is that 85 percent
of those solutions
require much more data sharing
across companies, individuals and cities.
So the question really comes,
how do we motivate companies
to share more of their data?
We need to actually
overcome this fear quickly
if we want to make meaningful
progress on climate change.
Well, as we talked
to a number of companies
that were building platforms
and ecosystems in different verticals
like logistics, transportation,
smart buildings, smart cities,
we asked about what it would take
to drive greater data sharing
across these different solutions.
And what we heard were the usual concerns:
data sharing is costly, it’s complicated.
And companies were concerned
about unintended disclosures
that could risk their brand.
However, there was one exception.
And this, I think, is promising.
Companies were more willing
to share their data
if it could serve a broader common purpose
beyond commercial motivations.
And in particular,
they're more willing to share their data
beyond their own four walls
if that data sharing could help
fight climate change.
Let's take, for example,
a few car companies
that actually are fierce competitors,
and they got together
and started to share detailed mapping data
so they could develop better solutions
for routing trucks,
so they spend less time idling
and also could route trucks in a city
based on prevailing
wind patterns to reduce smog.
These are pretty cool solutions
that companies are working on.
But the real question is,
if this common purpose
of fighting climate change
can help leaders overcome
their data sharing FOMA,
how do we get them to actually do it?
Well, in our work, we found
that it takes three actions
to jump-start a virtuous cycle
of data sharing and innovation.
First, companies need to look for new,
unexpected sources of data.
Second, they need to develop new
sustainability solutions quickly.
And third, they need to act
together for change.
Let's take finding new,
unexpected partners for data.
Well, what I mean by that
is looking well beyond
the four walls of a company
for sources of data that can be combined
with a company's own
to analyze and develop
new sustainability solutions.
But let me give a specific example.
Let's take farming.
Farming historically
has been more art than science.
You've had farmers that make
decisions on when to plant,
what fertilizer to apply,
when to irrigate, etc.,
based on their own personal experience
and knowledge of the farm.
Do you remember "Star Trek"
and when Spock could scan
the surface of a planet
to know what the habitat was,
using the sensors from the “Enterprise”,
and they could tell whether the planet
could support human life?
Well, I know I'm dating myself
and I'm a bit of a geek,
but that science fiction
is becoming a reality today.
You have data from satellites,
from drones, from sensors on the field,
from connected farming equipment
that is collecting data.
All of that can be combined
so that farmers can make
better real-time decisions on
how to improve their overall crop yield,
reduce the amount of fertilizer
and other chemicals they need,
and also conserve
scarce resources like water.
So they can improve their income,
lower their costs,
and now they can even start
generating new income sources
by planting carbon-absorbing crops
and getting paid for that.
So really quite fascinating
what's happening in agriculture.
Next comes innovating quickly
new sustainability solutions.
What I'm talking about is not
your typical long product road map,
but we need to have companies
hire data scientists
that can analyze all these
different data sources
and in new, agile ways,
bring new products and services to market.
We need to use data and digital quickly
to fight climate change.
Finally, acting together.
Now let me come back
to the smart-city example.
If we had transportation
companies and utilities
and buildings share data with the city,
then the city could make better decisions
on investing in renewable energy projects.
That could mean that you lower
your energy bill
and also reduce your carbon footprint.
Or that transportation data
can be used to decide
where charging stations are needed
so that we can accelerate the speed
of adoption of electric vehicles.
And that means maybe you spend
less time in traffic,
but also your air is cleaner.
So to really make progress
on more sustainable energy,
we need to have data sharing across
buildings, transportation and utilities.
All of this data sharing needs to come
together for a brighter future.
Now ...
You also have a critical role to play.
Of course, we individually need to be
in control of our own data.
Imagine you have an app
that allows you to set preferences
so that data from your car,
from your utilities,
from your shopping patterns can be shared
and you can make decisions
about your own carbon footprint
in a very easy way.
So you can run "what if" scenarios.
What if I purchase an electric car?
What if I take the train
from Boston to New York versus fly?
Or what if I change my shopping pattern
so I shop more locally?
How much will that impact
my overall carbon footprint?
Would you be willing to share more data
to have more sustainable climate
and to make those
climate-friendly decisions?
Well, I for one, I'm pretty
excited about this future,
a future where greater data sharing
can really help us
jointly combat climate change.
What we need is for company leaders
to move away from FOMA
and back to good old-fashioned FOMO.
The future is bright
if all that data can be shared,
and I don't think
we really want to miss out.
Thank you.
(Applause)